not a breaking news out of our nation's
capital Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski is on his way there right now
to meet with President Biden and also
address a joint session of Congress it's
his first foreign trip since Russia
invaded Ukraine almost a year ago this
was back in February and Ed O'Keefe is
at the White House following it all for
us Ed good morning quite a daring trip
it is Tony good morning President Biden
formally extended an invitation to
zielinski to visit the White House last
Wednesday he accepted on Friday and over
the weekend the office of speaker Pelosi
was informed Sitting In Motion a series
of elaborate plans for today's big
events
thank you
before leaving for the U.S Ukrainian
president Valor mirzolinski made a
surprise visit Tuesday with soldiers in
the front line city of bakmut
able troops handed him a Ukrainian flag
and alluded to it being delivered to
American leaders it's a visit that the
former U.S ambassador to Ukraine William
Taylor says the world is watching he'll
be telling Americans and the lawmakers
why it's important for Ukraine to win
the visit comes as lawmakers are
preparing to pass a federal spending
plan that includes about 40 billion
dollars in direct Aid to Ukraine
Wednesday Mr Biden is set to unveil a
plan for two billion dollars more and
that he plans to provide Ukraine with
training in the use of Patriot missiles
an advanced system capable of shooting
down aircraft and ballistic missiles in
any weather condition
the visit with Congress is also a chance
for the Ukrainian leader to speak
directly with skeptical Republicans
increasingly concerned about a blank
check approach as the GOP is poised to
take over the house in about two weeks
president zielinski needs to look the
American people on the eye and and
explain in a larger sense what the
struggle is all about
days since Russia began its invasion of
Ukraine and Relentless bombings have
plunged much of the country Into
Darkness he needs to hear from
American lawmakers but American people
American government that we understand
that he's fighting for their own liberty
but he's fighting for for our security
as well
now president zielinski is scheduled to
first come here to the White House for a
series of meetings with the president
and cabinet secretaries and hold a joint
news conference before heading up to the
Capitol where he set to address a joint
session of Congress later tonight Nate
looking forward to the results of that
sit down Ed thank you